[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin guten abend freut mich dass
sie dabei sind sowie kristin otto für
den sport freut mich auch guten abend
und hier sind unsere themen des tages
militärparade in moskau zum tag des
sieges erhebt präsident putin schwere
vorwürfe gegen den westen die
befürchtete generalmobilmachung bleibt
aber aus
kämpferische töne aus kiew präsident
seelands giebisch wird den sieg seiner
truppen die angriffe in der ukraine
gehen weiter
erste frau an der spitze des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes die neue vorsitzende
jasmin frattini will die organisation
jünger und weiblicher macht
[Musik]
was denkt putin was wird er als nächstes
tun seit wochen wird gerätselt und seit
wochen blickte man auch angespannt auf
den heutigen 9 mai dem tag des sieges
über nazi deutschland
bis dahin so viele experten müsse
russlands präsident seinem volk erfolge
vorweisen die sind nun in größerer zahl
bislang ausgeblieben aber die
befürchtete verbale eskalation putins
heute auch die parade zum feiertag ein
erbe der sowjetunion war immer schon
eine große inszenierung allerdings fiel
sie etwas kleiner aus mit weniger
soldaten weniger waffen und fahrzeugen
putin nutzte diesen sieges tag auch zur
machtdemonstration wir uns jetzt andreas
weise zeigt
es ist wie immer ein martialisches
spektakel die sieges parade auf dem
roten platz aufwendig in szene gesetzt
vom russischen staatsfernsehen ein
aufmarsch der waffengattungen allerdings
ohne luftwaffe offiziell wegen des
wetters mit spannung erwartet präsident
putins rede in seiner ansprache geht es
aber vor allem darum den angriff auf das
nachbarland zu rechtfertigen mit einer
angeblichen bedrohung russlands
wir hatten gesehen wie eine militärische
infrastruktur entfaltet wurde die
hunderte ausländische berater zu
arbeiten begannen regelmäßige
lieferungen modernster waffen aus den
nato-ländern erfolgten die bedrohungen
damit jedem tag zu russland hat der
aggression eine präventive abfuhr
erteilt
wie viele russische soldaten und
offiziere bisher in der ukraine gefallen
sind ist unklar doch wladimir putin will
vorbeugen wenn die zahl der särge die
aus der ukraine zurück kommen immer
größer wird verspricht den
hinterbliebenen großzügige hilfen
der staat die regionen die unternehmen
und gesellschaftlichen organisationen
werden alles tun um solche familien mit
fürsorge zu umgeben um ihnen zu helfen
besondere unterstützung werden wir den
kindern der gefallenen und verwundeten
kampfgefährten gewähren ein
präsidentenerlass dazu ist heute
unterzeichnet worden
nach der parade die sogenannte aktion
unsterbliches regiment russen aus allen
landesteilen tragen bilder von
gefallenen soldaten all der kriege seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg auch dem in der
ukraine und viele glauben ihrem
präsidenten in seiner geschichte
verfälschen erzählung von nazis in der
ukraine und dem bösen westen
wenn es da keine nazi regierung ergibt
wird es auch frieden geben
nun ich denke dass dies doch politik ist
und sie wissen dass wir nicht gegen die
ukraine sind sondern gegen amerika
kämpfen
immer wieder zu sehen dass z symbol es
soll einen sieg geben sagen viele hier
und sind damit ganz auf linie mit ihren
präsidenten
doch wie der sieg aussehen sollen wie es
im kampf gegen die ukraine weiter geht
darauf gab es zumindest heute keine
antworten
die parade und auch die rede putins hat
christian slam in moskau mitverfolgt
christian putin hat den krieg verbal
nicht noch weiter eskalieren lassen wie
muss man seine worte heute verstehen
[Musik]
der tag hat heute gezeigt dass ich
wladimir putin mal wieder nicht in die
karten schauen dass für all diese
szenarien die er vorher diskutiert
wurden ich finde das war heute eine rede
die war vor allem nach innen gerichtet
wladimir putin hat versucht dem
russischen volk noch einmal darzulegen
warum diese so genannte militärische
spezialoperation warum die so wichtig
sei und er hat dem westen noch mal den
die schuld gegeben an diesem konflikt
und er hat die verbindung gebracht zu
diesem historischen feiertag und hat die
vorkommnisse in der ukraine hatte mit
dem nationalsozialismus verglichen
zudem dieser feiertag gedacht ist zu
bedenken also hat er zwei sachen
miteinander vermischt was sie einigen
leuten bestimmt nicht gefallen wird
trotzdem
folgen die leute mir wär mir mit vielen
teilen seine argumente und folgenden
seinem kurs die stimmen die dagegen
sprechen sollten das muss man vielleicht
auch dazu sagen sie sind verschwunden
und jetzt wird hier gerade ein bisschen
laut jetzt komme die kehrmaschinen und
räume die reste weg von den
feierlichkeiten
vielen dank nach moskau christiansen ja
die ukraine die gedachten schon gestern
ihrer acht millionen getöteten
landsleute im zweiten weltkrieg aber der
ukrainische präsident see lenski hat
sich auch heute wieder mit einer rede an
sein volk gewandt einige stellen und
städte konnte das ukrainische militär
inzwischen zurückerobern ansonsten nur
wenig änderungen an den front verläufen
christoph distel fasst es zusammen
auch die ukrainischen veteranen sind
stolz in diesen tagen der sieg über die
nazis war auch ihr sieg doch in hf nahe
der russischen grenze können sie nur in
der u-bahn feiern denn oben wird die
stadt bombardiert von den nachfahren
ihrer eigenen kriegskameraden von damals
ein tragischer gedenkt tag
ihr präsident zielinski begeht ihn mit
einer neuen videobotschaft
fünf minuten lang aufwendig gedreht
spricht er in kiew zu den ukrainern vom
krieg zweier weltanschauungen vom
freiheitskampf seines landes und gibt
zum schluss ein versprechen
was sehr bald wird es in der ukraine
zwei tage des sieges zu feiern geben und
jemand anderes wird überhaupt keinen
feiertag mehr haben wir haben damals
gewonnen wir werden wieder gewinnen
derzeit aber läuft der krieg auch bei
krake wohl soviel artilleriebeschuss
kaum raumgewinn den ort mal hoch ein
etwa hatten die russischen besatzer
bereits vor einem monat aufgeben müssen
seitdem ist die frontlinie fast
unverändert und seitdem haben die
ukrainischen truppen im zerstörten maler
johann ein moralisches und zugleich sehr
praktisches problem was tun mit den
toten russischen soldaten
40 leichen haben wir bereits zusammen
und warten nun entweder darauf dass
unsere regierung sagt was mit den toten
geschehen soll oder auf eine anfrage der
russischen föderation
die aber so heißt es aus kiew habe sich
noch nicht um ihre toten bemüht außerdem
ist das bergen der leichen
hochgefährlich manche wurden mit
sprengfallen zurückgelassen wozu also
der aufwand fragen viele der hass auf
die besatzer ist groß
auch wegen mario pohl offenbar bleibt
die russische seite gnadenlos soll
gerade einen neuen versuch machen die
anlage zu stürmen nur noch etwa 2000
ukrainische kämpfer ausharren
in kiew ist für uns katrin eigendorf
kathrin wie fallen denn in der ukraine
die reaktionen auf die putin rede in
moskau aus
ja zunächst mal man kann das
wahrscheinlich hinter mir sehen wir
stehen hier im zentrum von kiew und es
hat hier gerade auch wieder luft alarm
gegeben das heißt die stadt ist
eigentlich fast wie ausgestorben im
vergleich zu dem wie sie sonst in um
diese jahreszeit aussieht die menschen
mit denen wir gesprochen haben haben im
prinzip sich so geäußert dass sie gesagt
haben dass das lade mir putin da gesagt
hat ist nichts neues wir erwarten von
dem russischen präsidenten auch weder
ein einlenken noch eine 1 sicht also man
hat das eigentlich relativ gelassen hier
genommen es gab ein paar kommentatoren
die sich sogar lustig gemacht haben über
wladimir putin wesentlich klarer und
harscher ist die position von vladimir
selensky ausgefallen der ja noch mal
ganz klar gemacht hat in
videobotschaften aber auch in anderen
statements dass russland die geschichte
nicht missbrauchen darf um diesen krieg
gegen die ukraine zu rechtfertigen und
er hat auch an die geschichte angeknüpft
und hat gesagt wir ukraine haben
nazi-deutschland zurückgeschlagen und
wir gedenken jetzt der opfer sie haben
der opfer am 8 mai gedacht und wir
werden wie wir nazi-deutschland
zurückgeschlagen haben auch russland
zurück ich zurückschlagen also auch hier
historische parallelen danke für die
eindrücke live aus kiew katrin eigendorf
zum heutigen neunten mal eben in diesen
besonderen zeiten gibt es gleich ein zdf
spezial direkt im anschluss an unsere
sendung
einen russischen diktat frieden soll es
nicht geben was immer wir tun stimmen
wir mit unseren bündnispartnern ab so
kanzler scholz gestern in seiner tv
ansprache
der wichtigste europäische partner ist
gerade zu besuch in berlin frankreichs
wiedergewählter präsident max spricht in
diesem augenblick mit olaf scholz mehr
zur visite von andrea maurer
es ist der erste auslandsbesuch des
französischen präsidenten nach seiner
wiederwahl und er führt emanuel marken
zu olaf scholz das signal kontinuität
der deutsch französischen achse
empfangen am kanzleramt mit
militärischen ehren im fokus des
treffens auch unterstützung für die
ukraine und wir sind uns einig die
ukraine gehört zur europäischen familie
wir arbeiten
daran ihr den weg in unser gemeinsames
europa weiter zu begleiten und da sind
jetzt die prozesse festgelegt die
europäische union
bearbeitet die vorgeschlagenen anträge
und die kommission wird bald ihre
bewertung vorlegen es geht auch um enge
abstimmung bei sanktionen
waffenlieferungen energieversorgung also
die tradition wir müssen die natur jetzt
einige entscheidungen auf europäischer
ebene treffen wir haben damit schon
angefangen aber wir müssen unseren plan
nun beschleunigen uns weniger abhängig
von russischem gas zu machen und unsere
wirtschaften besser zu schützen
zur stunde gespräch hinter
verschlossenen türen schon vor dem
treffen mit makro hatte kanzler scholz
angekündigt er wolle die einfuhr von
russischen gas und öl so schnell wie
möglich auf null senken aber eben keinen
sofort starb ich muss hier niemanden
sagen was etwa ein sofortiger stopp von
gas- für die chemie- stahl- oder
metallindustrie bedeuten würde niemandem
es damit geholfen wenn hier die lichter
ausgehen uns nicht und der ukraine auch
nicht ob sie selbst bald nach kiew
reisen dazu heute von makro- und scholz
kein wort
wir sprechen mit theo koll in berlin
theo worauf kommt es bei diesem treffen
an also heute ganz besonders sowohl auf
inhalte als auch auf symbol ist
symbolträchtig erneut die erste
auslandsreise des wiedergewählten
französischen präsidenten und inhaltlich
sucht man deutsche unterstützung vor
seinen schwierigen parlamentswahlen bei
denen seine partei die mehrheit zu
verlieren droht europäisch fordert
scholz die aufnahme des westbalkan makro
will mehrheitsentscheidungen in der eu
und eine art vorgeschalteten club für
demokratische länder die zwar
europäische werte teilen aber noch nicht
aufnahmefähig sind bei der ukraine könne
die aufnahme so sagt marco noch
jahrzehnte dauern beide wollen
ausführlich über gemeinsame rüstung
reden und darüber wie es in der ukraine
weiter gehen kann makro fordert einen
frieden ohne russland zu erniedrigen am
abend so hören wir besuchen beide das
brandenburger tor das in den
ukrainischen farben angestrahlt sein
wird auch das ein ausdrückliches symbol
gegen die bilder heute aus moskau theo
koll danke und grüße nach berlin was
wird aus der öl raffinerie im
brandenburgischen schwedt wenn kein
russisches öl mehr gekauft wird
wirtschaftsminister habeck versuchte
heute den 1200 mitarbeitern mut zu
machen könnte raffinerie der zukunft
werden vielleicht sogar für wasserstoff
noch gehört der betrieb mehrheitlich dem
russischen staatskonzern rosneft als
letzte möglichkeit sieht das gesetz auch
eine enteignung vor
das ist ein daniel günther sieg so der
tenor gestern abend nach dem wahlerfolg
der cdu bei der landtagswahl in
schleswig-holstein nach dem vorläufigen
amtlichen endergebnis hat sich die cdu
deutlich gesteigert auf
43,4 prozent auch die grünen mit plus
sie landen bei 18,3 prozent
die spd dagegen rutschte ab auf den
historischen historischen tiefstand von
16 prozent die fdp fällt auf 6,4 prozent
zulegen konnte der ssw mit 5,7 prozent
den sprung in den landtag schaffen weder
afd noch linke über die reaktionen in
berlin wo jetzt schon der blick auf den
kommenden wahlsonntag in nordrhein
westfalen fällt daniel thompson bei der
cdu war alles vom wunsch getragen dass
sein funkelndes ergebnis gestern
abstrahlt oft seines nächsten sonntag in
nrw sollte auch hendrik wüst als
ministerpräsident bestätigt werden wäre
das ein großer erfolg für seine partei
wer es zugleich innerparteiliche
konkurrenz mit blick auf die nächste
kann der kandidatur
ich habe nicht nur keine sorgen sondern
ich freue mich sehr darüber und empfinde
das mit als meine aufgabe also einer
meiner wichtigsten aufgaben dafür zu
sorgen dass wir junge
ministerpräsidenten hoffentlich auch
demnächst mal wieder ministerpräsidentin
in der führungsmannschaft der union
haben und ich freue mich über jeden der
erfolg hat wenige luxus problematisch
diesmal die lage bei der spd eine
niederlage war erwartet worden eine so
verheerende nicht ein trend ab er sei
dies keineswegs von neuen wahlen haben
wir sechs gewonnen in hamburg in
rheinland pfalz in berlin in mecklenburg
vorpommern die bundestagswahl und das
saarland dann war das kein schöner abend
gestern aber die spd ist stark und das
werden wir in dieser woche auch deutlich
machen werden wir den blick nach
nordrhein-westfalen richten weitere
wahlverlierer gestern die afg die
erstmals wieder heraus gewählt wurde aus
einem landesparlament mann soll
womöglich zu wenig unterscheidbar
gewesen so eine erste analyse samt
hoffnungs freudiger deutung das
enttäuschend für uns ganz klar aber wir
werden auch von dieser niederlage
profitieren indem wir aus der stärke
heraus zurückkommen werden stark war das
ergebnis der grünen im gegensatz zu dem
der fdp beide bisherigen jamaika partner
in kiel hoffen auf eine fortsetzung
ihrer regierungsbeteiligung eine
vorfestlegung von daniel günther gab es
auch heute nicht er werde mit beiden
sprechen
sie ist chemikerin
sozialdemokratinnen und seit heute ist
die jasmin fach chemie auch vorsitzende
des deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes und
damit chefin von rund 5,8 millionen
gewerkschaftsmitgliedern das waren schon
mal viel mehr aber als dachorganisation
von acht einzelgewerkschaften ist der
dgb noch immer eine wichtige größe
gerade in zeiten der verunsicherung mehr
von lars bohnsack und andreas ruppert
über 93 prozent das nennt man
vertrauensvorschuss jasmin fach chemie
ist die erste frau an der spitze des dgb
sie übernimmt den dachverband in auch
für gewerkschaften schwierigen zeiten so
gefährdet der ukraine krieg und der
damit drohenden energiemangel
arbeitsplätze in großem stil wenn morgen
die chemische industrie stillsteht gibt
es weder für die pharmazeutische
industrie noch für die landwirtschaft
ammoniak es gibt keine hightech
kunststoffe und lacke für windkrafträder
keine batterien für elektroautos und
keine dämmstoffe für die energetische
gebäudesanierung die gewerkschaften
verstehen sich traditionell als teil der
friedensbewegung trotzdem unterstützt
der dgb waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
und auch das sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr warnt aber davor deshalb
abstriche in der sozialpolitik zu machen
ich bestreite nicht
die notwendigkeit angemessene
ausstattung der bundeswehr aber es darf
kein freifahrtschein für militärausgaben
werden diese kosten die dürfen nicht auf
die beschäftigten abgewälzt werden die
tragen schon genügend lasten der kanzler
zu gast auf dem dgb kongress verteidigt
die hohen militärausgaben gibt herein
versprechen wir werden die projekte die
wir für den transformationen für die
neue ausrüstung unserer wirtschaft aber
auch für den sozialen zusammenhalt in
deutschland uns fest vorgenommen haben
nicht einstellen sie werden jetzt erst
recht nötig sein neben dem krieg in der
ukraine sind für den dgb die gewaltigen
umbrüche in der arbeitswelt wichtigstes
thema auf die neue frau an der spitze
warten große aufgaben
[Applaus]
die kriminalität im internet hat er in
deutschland im vergangenen jahr einen
neuen höchststand erreicht als ein grund
gilt die hohe nutzung digitaler geräte
während der korona pandemie wie das
bundeskriminalamt mitteilte stieg
insbesondere die zahl der erpressungs
fälle im netz dabei werden erbeutete
daten erst gegen lösegeld wieder frei
gegeben die schäden alleine dadurch
werden auf mehr als 24 milliarden euro
geschätzt
wir sind jetzt bei christlichen fußball
endspurt beziehungsweise in der
bundesliga endspurt und die beiden haben
ihre meisterschale ja schon passend zum
letzten heimspiel natürlich die erste
saison unter trainer julian jetzt mann
verlief für den fc bayern münchen
keineswegs glatt nur ein titel da sollte
wahrlich mehr rausspringen dennoch war
die ehrung des meisters nach dem
unentschieden gegen stuttgart etwas
besonderes die meisterschale für die
bayern wissen dass es user für julian
nagelsmann ein ungewohnter kraftakt
er war schon anstrengend muskelkater
brust tatsächlich aber es ging die
schwerer wie erwartet schlechter als
erwartet zuvor die leistung gegen den
vfb sehr stabil und hier thomas müller
machten aus einem 0 2 1 rückstand eine 2
2 1-führung dort der rekord champion
weiter mit großen lücken in der abwehr
die der vfb nutzte die sascha karadzic
der schütze zum ausgleich und die
stuttgarter hätten sogar gewinnen können
förster verpasste knapp 22 die bayern
wenig meisterlich und der vfb hat die
chance auf den direkten klassenerhalt
gewahrt und im
kampf um den lukrativen vierten
tabellenplatz der die
champions-league-teilnahme sichert hat
er bleibt sich nun am letzten spieltag
die beste ausgangsposition
die sachsen besiegten augsburg souverän
mit 4 0 und haben ist als vierter selbst
in der hand erneut die königsklasse zu
erreichen alle bundesliga highlights bei
uns online auf zdf heute.de und in der
zdf- heute
mühsam aber erfolgreich verläuft die
aufholjagd von weltmeister max
verstappen in der gesamtwertung der
formel 1 mit seinem dritten sieg im
fünften wm lauf bei der premiere in
miami verkürzte er seinen rückstand auf
spitzenreiter charlie claire der zweiter
wurde um 2 auf 19 punkte pech hatten
nick schumacher der kurz vor schluss auf
platz 9 liegen mit sebastian vettel
kollidierte und erneut ohne punkte blieb
so was nennt man wahrlich ärgerlich dann
sagen wir danke christine wir blicken
noch ganz kurz vorm aufs wetter morgen
früh sommerliche 25 grad und viel sonne
wo nicht das erfahren sie gleich von
katja horneffer um 21.45 begrüßte
marietta slomka zum heute journal das 19
uhr heute team sagt schön dank fürs
zuschauen und einen entspannten abend
für sie morgen an dieser stelle barbara
hahlweg
[Musik]
guten abend über tag entwickelten sich
einige quellwolken hier über den
mittelgebirgen aber auch in bayern und
am alpenrand da gab es dann noch einige
schauer und gewitter am nachmittag lagen
die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 17 und
26 grad und es wird eine milde
sommernacht in der westhälfte da sinken
die werte nicht unter 14 bis 10 grad im
osten und am alpenrand wird es kälter
mit 9 bis 4 grad zu beginn der nacht
kann es noch ein paar schauer oder
gewitter geben lösen die sich auf bildet
sich auch mal ein nebel häufig ist die
nacht klaren von nordwesten werde die
wolke und dichter morgen kann es dann in
schleswig-holstein etwas regnen sonst
wechseln sonne und wolken freundlich
miteinander ab und das ist keine gute
nachricht für den nordosten
denn da gibt es zurzeit eine extreme
waldbrandgefahr waldbrand gefahrenstufe
5 von 5 ist bereits erreicht die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee und auch
hier zwischen dem thüringer wald und dem
alpenrand bei 20 bis 23 grad sonst
werden frühsommerliche 24 bis 28 grad
erreicht und am mittwoch gibt es sogar
30 grad in der lausitz oder auch am
neckar danach geht es kühler und
wechselhafter weiter guten abend